um you recently gave nikki props for
giving you like one of your first
biggest breaks with the shyrock record
you know the beam me up scotty tape drop
but like
how how much did that kind of change
your world
initially when it happened cause her
fans are crazy people shout out to the
barbs you know what i'm saying
they're writers for real crazy crazy fan
but how did that initially happen like
how did she reach out give me the story
behind that shy rack record
man i was i probably was like 17 or
something this one i used to be just
thugging i wasn't really like chasing
music trying to make a real career out
this [ __ ]
but you know i had already made a name
for myself as far as like
lyrically and [ __ ] right you know um
and [ __ ] i was in the studio bro like
four in the morning some [ __ ] like that
it was late as [ __ ] night
and she had um they reached out they had
called my manager at the time like yeah
you know uh it's nicki these are you
know these sneaky people we want um
we're gonna hurry the slide we want her
to come right into la
and do a record you know we [ __ ] with
him and we were so
high like it's four in the morning we
have a lean
right we need all type of [ __ ] and we
didn't think it was for real we like man
ain't no [ __ ] nicki hang up and that
ain't dumb people and
they call back like a couple days later
like man what the [ __ ] is y'all alone
y'all not trying to come out
and do this record like damn they for
real it's really them and she put me on
the plane immediately i came out there
like two three days
met up with a guy in the studio she told
me how much she [ __ ] with me and she
pulled the record up and i did that
[ __ ] right on the spot
that shit's legendary yeah that [ __ ] was
crazy did she bring you out at summer
jam in new york because i was i was on
the side of the stage
for sure that was like summer jam that
was 2015
2014 2014. meek was on that show yeah
i think drake was there drake everybody
yeah no i was there
that [ __ ] was special then i met wayne
for the first time wayne was there
yeah yeah young money had that [ __ ]
showed up oh for sure that [ __ ] was
crazy but that had to be insane coming
out
as a kid summer jam stage bro hang on
lies so crazy i never
it was like surreal to me it ain't it
didn't even
like hit me when it happened you know i
wish i was like how i am now like
real focused and like confident because
right it didn't hit me like i didn't
even really feel like i was there bro
like even being on the stage
i couldn't even see all the fans i like
blacked out i was so damn nervous doing
some [ __ ]
i couldn't imagine you know i just came
out there and
did it real quick and didn't try to get
off the stage just as
quick as possible i ain't gonna lie to
you that's that's gotta be that's like
nerves that's some bucket list [ __ ] man